la 3008 couronnée voiture de l'année
2010 est un succès qui s'ajoute aux
bonnes ventes de la 308 et au lancement
réussi de l'opac grande lande x autant
de facteurs qui font que le site de
sochaux va produire 500 mille véhicules
cette année un essor jamais atteint
depuis près de 50 ans notre marché 3008
est plutôt ciblé sur l'europe et le sud
de l'europe alors que le gandin dit va
plutôt se positionner sur le nord de
l'europe avec l'allemagne et donc ces
deux marchés vont faire en sorte que ils
vont être complémentaires et que ça va
nous permettre d'atteindre le fil des
cinq cent mille pour arriver à cet
objectif
les ateliers de psa continueront de
tourner le vendredi le samedi et le
dimanche et du personnel supplémentaire
sera recruté pas dire que ça va être
simple pour les salariés on va veiller
ou sur les conditions de travail mais
ce sera possible on est quasiment à
500000 déjà cette année et dont l'air
urbaine de montbéliard
quand la santé de psa va tout va
notamment chez les équipementiers
automobiles euros fitting entreprise qui
produit des roues va s'agrandir avec un
bâtiment de 3000 m² afin d'accueillir
une troisième ligne de production
trente personnes vont être recrutées en
cdi
autre exemple avec flex n'guetta
audincourt ici on fabrique des pare
chocs et des haillons l'embellie chez
peugeot a poussé le directeur à investir
dans une nouvelle presses d'injection
plastique et une nouvelle ligne de
peinture
plusieurs dizaines de personnes vont
être embauchées
nous avons effectivement embauché
l'année dernière sur 2017 environ 70
intérimaires en cdi une trentaine de
manager et de techniciens et sur 2018
nous allons renouveler cette opération
avec environ 60 intérimaires qui seront
ils se verront proposer un poste en cdi
et une quinzaine de techniciens manager
supplémentaires grâce à peugeot
flexjet est devenu le deuxième plus gros
employeur de l'agglomération de
montbéliard